Hey,
what's going on is bill burns time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Yes.
Jackie,
just checking in on you.
You fucking who?
What's going on?
How are you?
Um,
oh,
this sound sound fucked up here.
You know what it is.
You guys probably want to wipe.
Why don't you,
when you get the fucking sound right,
why don't you just set it,
set it and forget it.
Remember that Shit you turn on and off and just forget about it.
Just fucking walk away from it.
I bought one of those things.
The thing was the shit,
I don't know.
I can't remember what ever happened to it.
Stick a whole fucking chicken in there,
you know?
And I would shut it,
but I would not forget it.
I would always remember that I had a chicken cooking cause I was living in New
York and uh,
you know,
I was paying nine grand a month for like fucking 30 square feet.
So,
you know,
I had my pillow propped up on the other side of it.
And you know,
it's impossible not to hear that bell go off considering a,
my head was against it.
You know,
half of my head would be sweaty and red and I'd sit down or eat a whole chicken
greasy is shit.
I don't understand why fucking chickens is so God damn greasy.
You know,
when you look at them they don't look greasy and that greasy shit.
And then,
you know,
what's the worst is your fucking show up and the amount of people that don't
know how to cook chicken and it's just fucking dry as chicken.
Do you know,
way back in the day,
back in the day when I was young and I had more hair,
um,
I used to do a what was called the uptown shows,
you know,
do the uptown shop town,
in my business is means,
uh,
the black shows,
the shows where the crowd is African American.
And uh,
every once in was like one white guy on the show,
one token white guy.
So I used to be the token white guy on those things.
And I remember all the fucking time I used to do these things and I hope he
hears just,
I used to work for a talent.
He used to do all those fucking rooms and they used to always give me shit,
say white people don't know how to have a cookout or barbecue,
whatever the fucking thing is.
And I'll never forget he invited me.
I can't remember.
Was it him?
A General Kelly?
They invited me up.
Where the fuck up in the Bronx?
I don't know where the hell it was.
It was just fucking like basketball slash do stand up during the day and this
basketball park.
So I have fuck it.
I'll go up there and do it.
So I went up there,
you know,
and they're fucking cook it up and all that shit.
And I got to tell you,
I will never forget how fucking disappointed I was when I ate the chicken.
It was so fucking dry.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Tell you everybody talks shit.
Ah,
fuck it dude is a fucking detail.
Go fucking do it.
I got it.
Oh,
you know what,
I should have Nia here for this cause that's another one too.
They always telling me how good soul food is.
I've been to one good soul food place.
That's the same thing with like barbecue too.
Everybody Raven above fucking barbecue.
90% of those things are absolute shit holes.
You walk in there,
you see like 50 health code violations is fucking flies and stuff.
Okay.
And then they just,
they try to disguise all their fuck ups with like fuck it and you know,
10 pounds of barbecue sauce.
I mean you put barbecue sauce on a tree branch,
it's going to fucking tastes good to some level.
Right?
MMM.
I found that all,
you know,
trying to,
you want the reality is is I don't know shit about barbecue.
So it's just like,
you know,
if you don't know shit about standup,
you're going to watch a bunch of hacks before you get to a good one.
So maybe that's what it is.
I have no idea.
The one place soul food place that I want that.
Actually,
I went to Amy Ruth's a long time ago and I liked that.
I thought that that was quality.
All right.
So I know it has to be out there.
I mean,
God knows if you want to get a good fucking corn beef sandwich,
I know the go down to Tom Bergen's here in fucking la.
Right?
I know where to go for that shit.
So somebody helped me out.
They in La,
where's,
where's a good spot for all of that type of stuff because I've,
I can't say it because it would be sacrilegious,
but I've gotten the most famous fucking,
mmm,
I guess soul food place out here.
There's two locations.
And I went to both of them and the food.
Absolutely.
Without a doubt.
No questions.
Landslide fucking sucked.
And I was like,
why is there a God?
Why is there a fucking line around the block for this shit?
It's terrible to has to be,
this has to be the spot that only guys like me know about.
Right.
And then everybody else is going to the real place.
MMM.
That was a fucking left turn.
I think you only get barbecue,
I think I ever really enjoyed was when I was in Alabama and there was a place
called a US smart ass Wilson.
It's still stood for and that shit was fucking delicious.
You go in,
the place was clean,
you know?
And they always have to have it be a little bit funky.
It kind of looks like,
do you guys build hot rods here or are you be you making a fucking,
you know,
brisket,
fucking pisses me off those.
Have you watched the food network and you watch those professionals doing it?
I'm always screaming at the TV.
Where do you,
where the fuck is your restaurant?
Okay.
I don't want to sit here and watch you cooking all this shit that I can't
fucking eat.
I mean it's works of art.
You know,
pill.
Make Barbecue of some fat motherfuckers though.
You gotta admit that,
right?
Just big fuck.
They literally,
they drive trucks.
MMM.
Anyways,
this is just making me hungry.
Speaking of which,
I've been eating like shit.
You know,
I know it's going to fucking tell you something.
I going,
what the Hell is talking about?
I start talking about fucking dry chicken.
Okay,
so fuck right.
Does it really matter?
I'm just checking in on you.
This is really isn't even a podcast.
Um,
anyways,
what
did I want to talk about?
Oh yeah,
so he give you the update on my,
uh,
now fuck that.
I'll do that later.
I,
um,
okay.
I fucking drank so much the other night,
right.
I had some friends of mine,
they were at this bar and they texted me going,
hey man,
we're out here drinking.
Right?
And I didn't want to drink.
She was really surprised.
I mean,
I always want to drink,
but I knew I shouldn't,
something in my head and my big stupid Charlie Brown head said,
don't go to the bar.
Right.
So I just,
you know,
they're like,
yeah,
we've been day drinking,
we're already here,
Yada,
Yada.
I'm just like,
okay,
blah,
whatever.
Right.
I'm not going to Wa
yeah.
And now,
you know,
I got a set tonight.
They're like,
yeah,
we'll right up the street.
Hit us up after.
And I was just like,
okay.
And that was just hoping they were going to be totally hammered and forget.
And I went down to the comedy store.
I've been doing sets all week because I got those huge shows this weekend.
And um,
I went up,
I had a fucking great set,
got all this new shit,
really excited about it.
You know,
cause I did just do a Gig in downtown La and one of my gigs is out in Riverside.
The other ones in Orange County.
My agent's telling me this is a completely different market,
completely different fireplace,
a little,
and I'm just worried that somebody from the show,
New Year's is going to show up.
So I gotta make sure I got a new 15,
20 so they don't be looking at those same shit.
Right.
Like I'm supposed to write a brand new ACA,
90 fucking days.
It's not even 90 days,
you know.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
I'm working on that shit.
And the second I get off stage,
I have a text,
hey man,
you offs you offs offstage yet,
but right down the street.
So like a fucking asshole.
Okay.
Don't listen to my gut.
I go down there,
right.
And I show up and it's everybody that I like to drink with and I'm like a fuck.
And I'm driving,
right?
So I go,
I'm going to have one whiskey,
I'm going to nurse it and that's going to be it.
Okay.
And I sipped it and it tasted fucking delicious.
And I literally looked at it,
another comic Hosea.
I go,
why does it taste so good?
And he just laughed.
He goes,
it tastes better every year.
And that's kind of the last coherent,
like part of the night that I remember I sucked at one down and then the
waitress came by and she goes,
hey,
gay gay,
right?
How's Hey your house?
And I was,
she didn't say,
you know,
she was actually,
completely,
uh,
probably probably did better in school than I did.
And I'm making fun of her because I'm set with the answer that I gave her.
I said yes,
as my brain's going,
don't do this bill.
Don't do this.
The second you get the second one,
now you have to fucking take a taxi home and you've got to leave your car here.
Don't do that.
Just fucking relax.
You know,
you're really just here for the social thing.
Just have a water and talk to the fellas.
Right.
So that's what I'm thinking.
And my brain just goes,
yes,
my mouth goes,
I would like another job.
And then that was it.
And then I just looked at everybody go,
well I'm not driving now.
And they go,
yeah,
you're not driving.
You're not driving.
And then that was it.
And um,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
And somebody told the fucking story about this drink called the John Riley and I
kept thinking it was like the actor John C.
Reilly.
So I kept picturing his,
his face as the guy was telling the story and I'm going like John see rallies
got is already has a drink named after him.
And that's,
that's like the,
like the bar version of winning like the Mark Twain Award.
Right.
I'm like,
good for John.
And it wasn't till he got like halfway through the story,
I realized he was just talking about a guide.
John Riley,
Eddie deep fucking did something.
He fought one of one of those.
We don't have those wars that they never make a movie about the Spanish American
war.
They never make a fucking movie about that in the Spanish American war.
Wasn't that the one we fought in the fucking Philippines?
I always thought that that one was like with Sam Houston and Dave Bowie.
David Bowie,
now Dan,
Daniel Boone,
whatever the fuck his name is,
right.
They surrounded the Alamo.
Let's see this here.
Spanish American war.
What do you put home?
Game away game.
How do I look this up?
Server not found the fuck are you talking about?
They would again.
You motherfucker.
Don't don't do this to me.
All right,
this is,
this is how I fixed it.
I shut it off.
Shut off Wifi.
Turn Wifi back on.
That's like the fibrillating.
Your fucking,
I say that word right.
Come on.
I feel like Pachino and and he got so bad.
All right,
here we go.
Spanish American war.
I think this was in the Spanish American war.
Wikipedia.
God knows they're always right.
Spanish American war was a conflict between Spain and the United States.
The result of the US intervention in Cuba.
Uh,
we've always been doing that.
Huh?
We are trying to make them free also.
All right.
Location,
Cuba,
Puerto Rico,
the Philippines in Guam.
Why don't they ever make a movie about that one?
I'm sure they did,
but why don't they make one that's fucking known enough that I've seen it?
Hang on a second.
I know I've ever even read about this was a conflict in 1898 between Spain and
the United States.
The results of US intervention in the Cuban war of independence.
In other words,
you know,
we,
we always have a dog.
We always have a dog in the fight.
You know what I mean?
You ever go to the fucking casino and there's that guy just fucking bet every
game.
That's the United States.
We always,
we always got some action going,
you know,
walking around with their fucking Hawaiian shirt and a big cigar flip flops.
We're a mess.
US attacks on Pacific Coast Pacific positions led to the involvement in the
Philippine revolution and ultimately to ultimately,
ultimately to the Philippine American war.
All right,
let's click on that Philippine American war.
It fucking lasted for almost two over two years.
1899 three years.
One month.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
that's three years.
Jesus.
Bill,
lay off the fucking sauce,
Huh?
MMM.
All right.
Filipino civilians dead.
200 to 250,000 dead mostly from disease.
We lost four to 6,000 they lost 12 to 20,000
okay.
We crushed another one,
Huh?
Jesus Christ.
We were on a tear back.
That was,
that's when we were really on a fucking tear.
Conflict Arose when first Philippine republic objected to the terms of the
treaty of Paris under which the United States took possession of the Philippines
from Spain ending the Spanish American war.
Yeah.
They like,
dude,
we want to be around people if you don't mind.
And then we came over their land to their home for a land of the brave free of
the home.
Whatever the fuck are our little tagline is.
And they probably scared up some guy named fucking Ulysses,
you know,
scare the shit out of,
they're going to come over here to going to get you.
They're going to get you fucking four wheeler.
Um,
anyways,
once again,
don't even know how the fuck I got to that God damn thing.
Oh yeah.
So the drink,
it's called the John Riley.
All it is,
it's,
it's a fucking Margarita.
And you take a shot at Jamison and you'd dump it in there.
And it had something to do with the fact that there was a bunch of Irish people
fighting on this side and they decided,
you know what,
you guys are fucking using us.
We're going to go fight on the side where the Latinos are.
So that's the Jamison going over to the other fucking side.
Right?
So now you've got whiskey though.
The bird,
the real tale of the tape here is now I got,
well,
what the fuck's in a,
in a,
in a Margarita.
Okay.
I never drink.
Is that,
is that Vodka Tequila?
I think it's Tequila.
Right?
And,
uh,
I fucking dumped that in there.
So now,
now I'm on my third fucking whiskey.
I had already ordered another Johnny Black because it was a really long fucking
story.
And now I'm three of those in,
I had a Jamison and then I had a fucking,
uh,
a Margarita and a,
I believe I had one more after that grant.
I did all of this.
I swear to God it felt like 90 minutes,
but I think it was about two and a half hours.
And,
um,
then I did the Irish goodbye,
which is,
I just hit me.
He's like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
And I didn't say goodbye to anybody and I just walked
doubt.
They called my old friends La taxi.
That's who I always call.
I do not Uber.
I don't do Uber because I just,
you know,
you do Uber.
It's gotta to be some young kid.
He's in the fucking business and he's going to hedge you a fucking script or
some shit,
you know,
and,
and eventually just say something really creepy like,
Oh,
you live here.
You know?
But yeah,
you get in the cab that just like,
hello.
Yes.
Hello my friend.
They don't give a fuck.
They don't,
they have no fucking,
you know,
they don't give a shit.
They're not trying to fucking do anything.
Right.
So I call La taxi like,
you know how many taxi have Ababa and I'm just like,
yeah,
just like,
yeah man.
And then there was just dead silence.
It in my fucking head.
It made,
they made me see,
made me think that they knew where the fuck I was at.
I wasn't at the Ramada,
I'm not going to say what the fuck I was at.
Right.
So,
um,
then I was just standing there swaying in the breeze and then one of my buddies
came down and his Uber pulled up and he just saw me and he saw the state I was
in any,
just let me get in it.
So I got in the fucking thing.
And like most streets in La,
they're the longest fucking streets ever.
You know what I mean?
Like last thing,
and again,
it starts at the Hollywood hills and we'll just go all the way down to like the
palace Verdi's peninsula.
Maybe that one doesn't,
but some of them do.
They like,
they're like fucking 20 mile long streets.
So you have the north side,
the south side.
This guy started going in the wrong fucking direction.
And fortunately I wasn't so drunk he would have dropped me off of the opposite
end of the fucking,
you know,
fucking city or whatever.
And um,
so I go to bed,
I don't even remember going to bed.
And then I wake up the next day I woke up at like eight in the morning with my
dog fucking licking my face and I swear to God,
at eight in the morning,
I was still legally drunk,
legally drunk.
And I was just like,
oh my God.
So I got up,
I walked the dog around the block,
I sat down and I just fucking,
it took me till about 10 30 to get my shit together and,
and I just walked all the way back to the bar,
the hotel area to get my fucking car.
Just a complete waste of a fucking day.
By the time I got home,
it was like one in the afternoon and I'm just muttering to myself the entire
time going,
look at this bill.
Would you look at this?
Look how many fucking times you got to learn this lesson.
And I would love to tell you that this is the last time I'm going to do
something like that.
It's the last time for a while I was a bad one.
That was a bad one.
But you know what was good was a,
I sold off some of them as the shit from my garage and I gotta tell you,
it felt good.
It made me want to get rid of a bunch of more on my shit.
Um,
I just got a ton of shit.
I don't know what that fucking and in order to do it,
and I'm telling you when I say shit,
it's fucking shit.
Bunch of baseball hats and fucking all these books and shit and just,
just stuff.
Got All this fucking shit and I'm sick of it.
It's all over the fucking place.
I don't use most of it.
So I'm,
I'm,
you know what,
I'm just going to,
I'm going to get rid of a bunch of shit.
I think good.
Where I'm going to start to do is every couple of days,
how many to give something away or sell something on Ebay?
I literally want to get down to basically bare bones.
What the fuck do I use?
Yeah.
You know,
I was thinking about that one on my long fucking walk of shame.
Back to my fucking car.
I saw this giant,
we didn't always Mayflower moving trucks just as jai,
the biggest one you could possibly get.
Or they even have like in between the front and the back wheels,
they dropped the backend,
the trailer down so they can even have shit down in there.
And I was just thinking like,
I never want to need one of those
ever.
Okay.
You gotta be that guy that can fuck up the next size up from the u haul van.
That's what the fuck you need.
Right?
I want to be laying in bed.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Oh Geez.
I got a ton of shit to tell you guys.
So I also,
I also want,
I looked at cars before my fucking
like big,
uh,
fucking booze fest and uh,
I thought I finally found my car and uh,
I swear to God,
I love the picture of it.
I went and I looked at the 2016,
uh,
Cadillac CTSV oh wait,
no,
the top of the line one,
whatever the one that,
the one,
it basically it goes fucking,
it goes 200 miles an hour and it's a four door sedan.
Right.
And I'll,
all I'm thinking is that I'm just like,
all right,
this is the fuck and this is the one,
it's exactly what the fuck I want.
I can't explain it.
I love the way it looks like in the picture.
And then I went to go see it and it just looked like something that you'd buy if
you were in,
like if you were in your twenties,
if you could somehow afford it just with all the fins and the tail fin.
Of course.
I'm just like,
I can't get in my driveway because the front ends to fucking low.
There's a little hump to get in my driveway.
And then they go and like,
well you could back it in and um,
okay.
I don't know man.
I just couldn't get past.
And then they were like,
yeah,
Justin Bieber bought one of these.
And I'm like,
yeah,
exactly.
He should buy one of these.
If you could walk around shirtless,
putting one my brow up and doing the kissing your two fingers in the peace
thing,
that's the fucking car for you.
I can as an almost 50 year old fucking man walking that thing.
I got to tell you,
I love the inside of it and it went like nine zillion miles an hour,
but I got to admit,
I fucking,
uh,
okay.
I realized while I was test driving the car that I am an old man and I don't
like going fast.
I just like cruising.
So
I looked at the other Cadillacs like the $54,000 fucking old man one,
it was 54 fucking thousand dollars and I can not stress enough what an absolute
piece of fucking shit it was.
I could have put my foot through the fucking door.
I literally left just like depressed.
I was just like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
Fuck all of these fucking things.
I'm just going to keep driving my fucking piece of Shit Prius.
Right.
And it really is a piece of shit at this point.
Now the engine is fucking great,
but like I've had all the dense take it out and everything,
but it sat in the sun for fucking eight years.
It's been hit too many.
It's punchdrunk my car is fucking punched drunk.
So last night I'm at the comedy store.
Oh,
by the way,
the Lincoln knew Lincoln continentals coming out in August,
2017 and a,
it looks pretty fucking bad ass.
And it's just like,
you know,
I was talking to a comic last night and I was joking about how old I am that I,
I like comfort over speed at this point.
And he goes,
oh yeah.
He goes,
you know,
you're out here in la.
He goes,
what the fuck are you going?
What are you going to go the fuck are you gonna go?
You can't go anywhere.
You want comfort,
you're going to be stuck in traffic.
Just drive around in the living room.
And it just totally made sense.
It's like,
yeah,
that's what the fuck I want to do.
Then of course,
I drive down to the club that night,
right?
And all of a sudden,
I swear to God,
I don't know if every,
these are a bunch of tourists and they all rent,
rented the cars.
There was a fucking guy in a white corvette like 2016 corvette,
a guy in a fucking 2016 brand new fucking Ferrari,
spider,
whatever the fucking thing is.
And then somebody else with this,
you know,
one of those BMW,
the m ones,
m three m five or something,
and they're all zigzagging or not a stop and go traffic revving the engines and
all that shit.
The exact thing that my buddy was saying and I was going,
look,
look how I was thinking that I'd be thinking,
look how dumb that is.
And all I was thinking was,
look how fucking great those cars look.
But of course everybody in them was 20 something,
you know,
the Yolo guys,
you Yolo doses,
right?
I mean,
I just have to fucking old,
right?
So,
um,
anyway,
so I went down to the store last night comedy store and I fucking a,
I did a set once again and I wasn't really even funny last night.
I mean,
I did a decent enough job.
I've been doing it long enough where I can fake my way through my job,
but I just kept having brain farts and all that cause I was still fucking hung
over.
Right.
So,
and when I'm hung over and I'm kind of in a grouchy mood,
my shit goes from fucking silly to like,
dude,
is this like a meeting?
This guy sounds like an insane person.
And,
um,
I got out of the club and I was walking to my car and,
uh,
this guy comes up,
he goes,
excuse me,
Mister [inaudible],
Mr. Byrd,
another reason why I shouldn't buy a fucking cool sports car.
When somebody pushing 30 calls,
you,
Mr.
It's tied to get yourself a Buick Riviera,
right.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You can't fight it.
He can't fucking fight it.
I am in my sport coat luxury car,
you know,
fucking years.
I'm going to go fucking,
I'm going to go online and buy an olds cutlass or something like that.
Um,
old cutlass is actually a cool coat.
Am I talking about whatever the fuck in a delta 88 or some shit.
Um,
so he comes up and he's with his girlfriend and he goes,
yeah,
I just want to say,
you know,
I really enjoyed the show.
A big fan.
I got thanks for whatever.
And then his girlfriend just standing there.
She goes,
yeah.
I'm not a big,
she goes,
yeah,
I don't like you.
Right.
Cause I was trashing the ladies,
right?
She goes,
I don't like you.
And I go,
yeah,
okay.
I just went,
all right.
And then she goes,
no,
I like you.
And she goes,
I like you,
but,
and I'm like,
here we go.
Here we go.
It's just like we had just get on with fucking trash in me.
You know,
that fucking female manipulation thing.
She said,
I don't like you because she was expecting that I gave a fuck.
We got to go,
what do you like me?
And then she could tell me what part of my act she didn't like.
And guess what part it was only the shit about me trash a women.
All the other stuff was perfectly fucking fine.
I'm talking about drunk driving and going to Mcdonald's.
Right.
She didn't have a fucking problem with that.
All the hypothetically like innocent people during that joke that I could have
fucking gotten in trouble,
you know,
could have run over.
Right.
She didn't give a fuck about that.
So she looks,
she goes,
I don't like you.
And I said,
I'll coach.
She goes,
no,
I like you.
And then like a fucking rookie.
I stopped.
She goes,
but you shouldn't be trashing him.
And it's just like,
ah.
I hate to say I don't give a shit.
I don't give a fuck either.
Dead after this show,
heckling is my number one pet peeve.
I stood on stage for 20 fucking minutes,
right in your crosshairs,
you know,
yell out something.
Then you don't say shit.
You just fucking sit there.
And then after the show you come up to me in the parking lot and you ignore the
30 topics.
I went,
I talked about those were,
those were all fine and he'd just talk about the one that pertains to you.
So I just said,
you know,
I don't give a shit,
right.
So I get in my fucking car and she,
but this point,
she was yelling at me.
MMM.
And this is hilarious.
She goes,
Oh my God,
I forget.
She was like,
man,
I have that.
I wasn't listening.
And she goes,
and you drive a fucking pray
study yelled at me about my car.
Oh,
he's fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious.
She,
when she yelled fucking Prius,
she had turned around and cause she realized that wasn't going to listen to her
bitch moaning,
complaining about my jokes.
She had already turned away and she goes up fucking,
she'd throw her head back.
She goes out fucking pres.
And uh,
what she,
what she did there,
she made me laugh harder than I probably made the whole crowd laughed my entire
set in that moment.
So thank you to that woman.
And uh,
you know,
other than that,
I don't know what to tell you.
Next time heckle me on stage and I listen what you have to say.
That was a fuck a woman heckled.
Me and the crowd.
Oh,
I'll tell you how to rough one,
you know.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Um,
all right.
Before I,
before I end voice,
Start Doing some of these reeds here.
Uh,
what the fuck is it?
Yeah.
Phife Dawg from tribe called quest passed away.
Man.
I was one of the,
a casual fan of that.
You know,
I'm just too fucking white.
I missed it.
I totally missed the boat.
You know,
I saw Michael Rappaport's documentary on him and I'll just maybe feels like,
how the fuck did I miss this shit?
Oh,
that's right.
Cause I was listening to warrant.
Um,
I have man that fuck it,
but I,
even though I didn't listen to the band as much as I should have,
it really forced fucking depressing.
Um,
just cause I obviously had friends die at that fucking age from that shit.
Complications from diabetes and all that.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
that's just getting old.
Sucks.
Just fucking blows.
45 years old.
How the fuck do you come to terms with that?
You know,
why did I bring it up?
I knew it was going to be depressing.
All right,
let's read some advertising.
All right.
Score big.
Uh,
you're paying too much for tickets between all the markups and last minute
convenience charges.
Oh,
by the way,
you know I asked this before,
how to fuck.
Is there a way that I can sell tickets to my show?
Just off my website and only fans will get them.
Like what stops these people who go in and somehow cause they got the money,
we'll go out and buy like 500 fucking tickets and then jack the price up and
then everybody gives me shit on the Internet.
Go look dude,
you phony.
You're not this phony.
And then they show how much the tickets are for and the amount of times they
call my age and going through what the fuck are we doing here?
And he's like,
that's not us.
That's those constant by a thousand tickets and then rape everybody.
If anybody knows away.
You know what's hilarious?
I think this advertising might be the way.
I have no idea between all the markups that you know what these guys are doing.
These guys are going to undercut stub hub.
This is actually probably a good thing here.
All right?
I'm not saying these guys aren't dirt bags too,
but you know what?
You can't just have one dirt bag.
You know if you get to dirt bags,
they start fucking going at each other and then you slide under the radar.
Right?
Anyway,
she paid too much for tickets between all the markups and last minute
convenience charges.
Even print at home fees.
Question Mark.
Exclamation point.
You can end up paying courtside prices for nosebleed seats.
scorebig.com is here to change that.
Well,
well,
well
let's see.
Let's see you guys.
You guys check this thing out and let me know if this is legit.
Did you know that 40% of all live event tickets go unsold and did you know that
there's a place to get these seats at huge savings?
It's called score big.com.
Okay?
In other words,
you bought up 40% of the tickets.
What do you mean they go unsold?
No,
they don't.
Well,
they don't,
this is all bullshit.
Yeah.
40% go.
One sold.
Yeah.
And then you want to do,
they probably would fucking cancel the show.
The acts not making the venue any money.
All right.
You know what I,
I'll,
I'll suspend disbelief here.
You know,
considering Batman versus Superman is going to be coming out this week and
you've got to suspend all that disbelief that a guy from another fucking planet
that can fly and bullets barn off this bounce off his chest is going to have a
fucking fight against the,
uh,
human being who has a fucking utility belt,
right?
Bullets bounce off his chest.
What is Batman going and what does he have in his little fucking tool belt there
that can fuck with that guy?
If they really made this movie as real as possible?
Batman versus Superman,
it's going to go down like one of those old school Mike Tyson paper views.
Remember that the fight would be over before the pizza showed up.
Yeah.
But you know,
somehow they'll don't fucking,
I don't know what they'll do.
They'll keep it going.
I love how they're out of victims.
There are that like villains and now they have to fight each other.
You know what I mean?
Like what does that say about superheroes?
I think that just they're just into fighting.
They don't give a fuck whether somebody's good or bad.
They just,
they just need,
they need to fight somebody and then when they stop all the crime and they think
they're going to relax and get themselves to the new 2017 Lincoln continental,
you know,
maybe chill on the whole flying and all that stuff.
Get themselves some adult clothes,
right?
What do they do?
They start fighting each other.
Fucking animals.
All right.
Scorebig works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get their unsold
seats.
It at unpublished prices only at ScoreBig Dotcom.
Can you name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60%
off the fuck outta here.
Here's what you do.
How are you under cutting the venue?
One.
Go to score big.com and find the event and seats.
You want to make an offer with the score.
Biggs name a ticket price features 17 get an instant answer and save up to 60%
on your tickets.
No surprise fees and free shipping.
Just unbeatable prices on great seats.
And when you,
you're in Greg seats,
you actually enjoy the game or show all the more,
well,
I hope these guys are legit.
Next time you go to see any shoe game or show,
go to score big first to see how much they can save.
Go to scorebig.com right now.
Click even if you don't have a show you want to go to,
just go to it.
Click on the microphone,
enter the Promo Code [inaudible] and you'll save an extra $20 off your first
ticket.
Purchase that scorebig.com promocode bar score,
big.com Promo Code burr a look who's back.
Look who's back speaking to the Spanish American war club.
Kelly club.
Debbie,
I'm a warp time president.
Uh,
we've all been there.
You come home after a long exhausting day at work and all you want to do is slip
a glass slip,
slip,
slip a quarter,
my Cosby sip a glass of wine.
Slip a fucking roofie in somebody wanting sip,
a glass of wine and relax.
But unless you've planned ahead,
you probably don't have a bottle in your house.
And getting up and going to the store is not happening.
Uh,
with club Debbie happened when a Red Tab,
I'm on the red tag team.
You can,
you can finally relax because you'll never have to worry about being wined free
again to Debbie.
Embedded in Jab Jab,
couldn't make it through the primaries is a new wine club that sends you wine
directly to your door,
saving you all those trips to the grocery store.
Not only does club Debbie,
you're going to stop chair.
And one more time.
Praise and evil doers.
Send your wine,
said you wine,
they'll send you wine that you'll love drinking club.
Debbie,
let me introduce you to my older brother,
older brother Jim.
He's not as good as me.
Easy six question quiz figures out your palate.
So every bottle you receive is perfectly tailored to your tastes club.
Debbie,
you still ain't be an alcoholic.
Now I can speak Spanish.
Works directly with the vineyards to cut out the middlemen,
which saves you money.
Club.
Debbie,
I got no more George Bush.
George even offers a no risk guarantee that you'll love what they said you call
to action offer right now.
Club Debbie Club.
Debbie,
you knew what I was in 2000.
He's still reelected me in 2004.
How dumb are you?
Is offering listeners $20 off your first order when you go to club Debbie,
Dick Cheney really ran the whole thing.
Dot Com slash burn and yet it gets even bad,
Huh?
Okay.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club Debbie will actually pay for your shipping on orders of four bottles or
more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to club w.
Dot com slash bird to get $20 off your first order.
Now it's club bibby.com/bird fool me once.
Shame on you.
Fool me
twice.
You're not going to fool me gear.
Um.
All right.
Is that the fucking podcast here for this week?
Uh,
yes.
I believe checking in on you.
The all checking in on your podcasts.
Let me guys let me know.
Um,
I know his shit on that sponsor a lot.
They're probably not going to advertise with me anymore,
but you know,
Yay.
You know,
Shit happens.
Um,
the fuck do I just have a socket here for
anyways?
Yeah.
So I'm going to start selling some shit on Ebay and I was actually thinking that
this is not much,
I want to start to sell one shit.
I was thinking of fucking taking my truck out to my shows this weekend and just
bringing a bunch of shit in the back.
It just,
just shit,
you know,
Shit.
To me,
somebody else might like it,
the end of the show just fucking given it to people,
you know,
just getting it out of here and then somebody else takes it and they like it
because if I throw it out and ends up in the fucking ocean,
but if I fucking just give it to somebody,
they can keep it in,
in their,
in their bedroom or in their fucking living room away from the poor purposes.
MMM.
I know.
It's just an idea.
Just an idea.
I've decided I'm going to start with the fucking closet in my,
in my bedroom.
I'm just going to go in there.
I want to,
I'm going to tab to fucking piles.
Shit.
I need shit I don't need and um,
I'm going to write it on a post.
It stopped being a sentimental bitch.
Get rid of this shit.
Whatever I need to do to just fucking plow through and get rid of all of this
stuff because I'm
okay.
I'm not,
I don't,
I just don't want all this shit anymore.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast this week.
You guys have a wonderful weekend and I'll uh,
talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]
that is,
it built a bit of a dilemma here for you.
I'm an 18 year old male who's about to graduate from high school.
Congratulations.
Um,
over the past few years I've been told I'm a really good dancer.
Uh,
not ballet or artsy stuff,
but just good dance floor dancing.
Oh my God,
I'm going to take over the dance floor.
Hey,
Angie watched me yet.
John Travolta.
This is great.
Do you go out to the Staten Island Bridge and do headstands with your,
with your buddy Bobby?
You know,
if he didn't have an Afro,
he never would've fell off that bridge if you had it high and tight.
Like all these Armenians out here,
all,
every Armenian looks like they know,
uh,
they know,
um,
MMA moose last time you saw an arm Armenian dude in his twenties or thirties,
and he did not look like he could put you in an arm bar within two seconds if
you want it to.
If I were,
if I was a Dana white and I was running the UFC at one point,
that this point where they're up to like what?
Like UFC 2006 you know,
they like running,
they've run out of adjectives this time.
It's really,
really personal,
right?
Not Saying I'm not a fan,
I'm a huge fucking fan.
I'm just saying,
you know,
the way that they have those things like every other week and there's only so
many like,
you know,
redemption.
I mean you've running out of words.
Um,
I'm such a fucking idiot.
This is what I would do if I was dating white at some point I would have,
you know,
you know what I would,
this is what I would branch off.
And when they had those tough man competitions and they would have just people
coming in,
throwing haymakers,
which is some of the best boxing Everest,
when you watch people who just aren't trained whatsoever and they just start
because somebody is going to connect,
right.
I think that they should have one week they should have the Armenians verse the
Russians tough man competition.
Because I really think that that needs,
it needs to be decided.
Who is the tougher of the two,
uh,
cause up one night when it comes to white people.
That's,
that's who I got my money on.
All right.
That,
those,
those are the crips and the bloods of white people is the army and the Russians,
all of them.
They just have that vibe,
that something you just like.
Yeah.
I'm not fucking with that guy.
Just really,
I'm really not doing it anyways.
Uh,
not a ballet or artsy stuff.
but just ballroom dance in a full contagion over here.
Uh,
I kind of think of think dancing is gay from an outside point of view.
Um,
I,
I it isn't,
it really isn't,
that's just how white people look at it.
It's considered gay cause it involves like letting yourself go and actually
admitting that you have emotions as a man,
as a white male.
Yeah.
Can,
yeah,
it is.
It's considered gay.
Um,
as his crying,
as is showing any sort of emotion as is not dying for no good God damn reason
before you're 56,
um,
oh,
not dying.
I should say,
if you live to be 60,
I believe amongst white men,
that's also considered gay.
Cause that means at some point you cried something out of your chest and he
didn't have a heart attack.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
I think dancing is gay from an outside point of view,
but I'll be the first one to admit that I'm actually a pretty good dancer if I
didn't think so,
I wouldn't be out there doing it.
Yeah,
but dude,
you gotta be getting some.
I'll,
I'll fucking women love a guy who can dance.
Dude,
if you could dance and you're wearing like a silk scarf,
it's fucking over.
It's going to be rain in Pussy.
As far as my outside view,
my freckled view from over in the bar trying to stand out from underneath those
hot lights so I don't get burned.
Uh,
you know,
red heads were the closest thing to vampires.
You know,
we have,
we have none of the powers of vampires,
but the sun affects us the same.
Okay.
A friend of mine who was a female dancer,
keeps telling me I could make money doing it on commercials or music videos.
Parentheses close on.
Or You could go to fucking Broadway.
It'd be like one of the five straight men who dances on Broadway and just tag
every fucking lonely chick out there who's all stretched out.
Just make sure you keep those shoes on.
Dancers' feet are always fucked up.
Uh,
here's where it gets complicated.
I plan on becoming a policeman.
Oh Dude,
this is,
this is a no brainer.
You need to dance it.
Bachelorette parties dressed as a cop.
All you need,
dude,
is that a big uniform on a boombox and you're on your way to make him money?
Dude,
you should fucking do that in a second.
And then you write a book about it.
I was a GI rate and cop for Bachelorette parties.
You write a tell all book about how many fucking broads,
who bought ready got married,
get married,
sucked your Dick.
You really need help on this one.
I mean,
I'm going to read the rest of it,
but I think I've already come with the solution anyways.
How is anyone to take me seriously on the force?
If there's a video going with me,
pop and locking next.
A little Wayne.
At the same time,
I'll,
dude,
you should fucking pull people over.
You should pull people over and fucking moonwalk up to their car and just freak
them out.
Even if they were reaching for a gun,
they'd be laughing too hard and they,
they,
they wouldn't shoot you.
Then you could rest them and then you move up.
Next thing you know,
you're a commissioner.
Alright.
Nothing anyways,
at the same time,
I'm getting laid a lot because of it.
Of course you are.
I'm a seven on a scale of 10.
I like this guy.
He's honest and um,
uh,
and like having a jump shot.
It's put me up to an eight five.
I'm bang and tense.
I've always wanted to be a cop at the parks here.
Seen better if I was able to make money doing it.
Other than the dancing thing.
I wouldn't just be getting Hummerus for letting gross moms off on speeding
tickets.
I could be bagging J lo.
She's into dancers.
Right?
Thanks.
Yeah,
Dude.
Apps a Fuckin lutely
dude.
You're basically saying,
what should I do here?
Should I bang j Lo's beat down at the club and make all this fucking money or
should I take a job where I'm going to get shot at and,
and not be appreciated?
You know,
I'll tell you every cop out there with dance,
if they could as opposed to be a cop,
I don't care if they had like seven generations in.
Dude,
this is what I think of as far as like dancing.
I think if I,
if I
like compare it to being a comedian,
oh the open mics would be getting a piece of cardboard and being on a subway
platform,
making money that way.
And then when you move up to hosting a show that would be addressed as a cop and
you fucking dance it.
Bachelorette parties,
that's what you do on the side.
That's like your fucking day job.
That bullshit.
And then during the day,
I,
yeah,
I would try out for those.
Fuck,
I don't,
did they make music videos anymore or fucking,
uh,
I dunno.
I believe it or not.
I don't know how to climb the ladder as a dancer.
But dude,
apps a fucking lutely if you can make money doing that shit.
And then what the great thing is,
is once you get to a certain level to,
to,
uh,
make more money,
you don't want,
you got some credibility.
You can,
you always have the,
the fall back where you can teach a class they get,
you can be like,
I dance for nine years and Chitty Chitty Bang Bang and fucking banged every
fucking brought on there.
And then if you'd like to not have,
fuck the women in your cast while still not losing your job,
come on down the Frankie's 12th in Dade Studio,
whatever.
Just you'll figure it out as you go in there.
And um,
yeah,
absolutely.
Absolute fucking Luli.
I would definitely do it.
You want to do what?
He wouldn't taken the time,
mmm.
To write in.
So your big fears should be whatever.
But everybody's big fear is like,
what if I fucking go after this dream and I'm 30 and I'm sleeping on a Fuckin
futon and it hasn't happened yet.
Well,
I got to tell you something,
sir.
I'd been there.
I was there at fucking 34.
I was still sleeping on a Futon in a fucking studio apartment that they called
the one bedroom,
cause they slammed a fucking wall in there
and put a door on it.
And then one day I was trying to bang the girl upstairs who had the fucking
apartment right above me.
And it was the exact same unit.
And hers was a studio,
but she had been there longer,
so they never slammed a wall in there.
And I realized,
Hey,
wait a minute,
I'm getting fucked.
You know,
I should go down there and try to get some money taken off of this.
I should go down to the,
uh,
they're fucking me over rental board.
But I didn't,
I said,
fuck it.
Just keep writing jokes.
Right.
So whatever,
oh,
you gotta do,
you just got to commit to this shit.
And,
uh,
and then realize that,
you know,
sleep on food tone when you're 30 is not the worst thing.
It isn't.
You don't see when,
you know,
it's worse than sleeping on futons at 30,
sleeping in a king bed next to a fucking woman you're not really love with,
but for some reason married and,
uh,
you got a couple of kids and you've got a job that you fucking hate.
Okay?
You'll be laying there fantasizing about fucking sleeping on a,
on a,
uh,
on a futon there.
There's no risk when you go after a dream,
it's all fucking reward.
It's all going to lead to something good.
It always does.
There's a tremendous amount of risk to playing it safe and uh,
that leads to unbelievable levels of regret,
which is something else I've also experienced cause I'm an [inaudible]
motherfucker.
I be happy.
Surprise.
We're getting a divorce.
All right,
here's a new story.
All right.
Hey Bill,
I know you have,
you aren't a therapist,
but I think I just want to talk to anyone at this point.
So here goes,
I've been married for just under four years.
To my wife who I dated for four years prior to marriage.
I love being married and have said that to anyone that asks.
Since day one,
we own a nice house together.
We have three dogs,
pit bulls,
too.
Good man,
and both make a decent living.
I share everything in my life with my wife.
Uh,
when something makes me happy,
she knows when I'm upset about something.
I tell her,
uh,
throughout the course of our relationship about once a year she would suddenly
without warning,
say she,
she was unhappy and has been for months.
Oh God.
Here we go.
Uh,
she says she has discussions with their mom who loves me and it's the sweetest
woman alive and close friends about the things that make her unhappy by and
never hear a word about it until it boils over.
And she floors me with how unhappy she is.
Well,
that's not fair.
All right.
We tried to work it out though.
Make changes.
She would act like it was okay while it bottling it up again once,
once the lid goes on the bottle,
there's no opening.
And again,
each and every time she calls the unhappiness state of the Union meeting into
session.
I've always been completely honest in saying that I'm very happy with her.
I love our jokes and honesty and honestly enjoy spending time and Papa,
Papa,
Jesus Christ to get to the fucking point.
All right,
last Wednesday.
Here we go.
We had a good night together.
We went out for dinner and ice cream and laughed at about Alibaba,
Bob boss.
So I thought I'd come home the following night in general,
great mood.
And she told me she had talked to her mom and a friend and that they recommend
that she talks to me.
I was confused
and Oh shit.
About not being unhappy.
Uh,
anyways,
I wanted anything to make her happy,
but she told me she didn't think there was anything.
It was very emotional as she finally mustered up the courage to say that we
might need to get separated.
I was floored and not in an almond asshole husband that sits around drinks,
beer and watches football with his buddy way.
I love my wife.
We have free.
Okay,
dude.
Okay.
Uh,
so the following day after much reluctance I get her to agree to try marriage
counseling so we can work out our happiness do and I'm not giving you shit that
this is,
you're pouring your heart out cause this shit just happen.
I understand.
But for the sake of the listeners,
I got to fly through this.
Um,
I get to agree with her.
I get to,
I get it.
Okay.
So the following day,
it's like Lord of the rings here,
after much reluctance,
I get her to agree to try marriage counseling so we can work out her
unhappiness.
I was willing to do anything at this point.
I immediately scheduled an appointment with the counselor and was looking
forward to having someone neutral for us to talk to.
Later that night we were laying in bed and I asked her if there was someone else
in her life.
She said,
no.
Yeah Dude.
Oh Jesus.
Uh,
Jesus,
here we go.
We just went over the waterfall folks or where we,
you know what it is not all in this story.
We were hearing the waterfall and we've just looked at the other person in the
raft with a panicked look on her face for that split second before we tried to
desperately.
But she literally try and paddle the fucking thing over to the Goddamn coast.
Okay,
here we go.
We're going over.
I got a feeling we're going over.
Um,
she said no,
there's no one else in my life.
I asked her if she's ever been unfaithful in our relationship relationship and
she adamantly said no again.
Then she turned out the light and laid down to sleep five minutes later and she
sat up and turn the light on a fuck.
She told me she just lied to me and said that she had messed around with someone
a year into our marriage.
And he writes in capital letters,
what period?
The period fuck period.
I probed her to tell me what messing around was as gotta.
At least
be a blowjob.
Okay,
ha ha ha,
ah,
fucking whore.
Um,
and after a minute of me guessing her silence told me that she went
down on a guy she works with.
Okay.
Swear to God.
I hadn't read this.
Okay.
Oh,
if I was Versie right now what I say,
you heard me.
You heard me
a fucking creep.
I was furious and hurt.
Then furious again.
She cried and cried and said she was sorry.
We cried together.
Dude,
you're a bigger man than me.
While I tried to wrap my head around how she could possibly have done that to
me,
I've had casual flirting with people over the years,
but to act on something physically with someone other than your spouse's,
completely disgusting.
To me,
the worst part is I love this woman more than anyone.
She's been my og.
Here we go again.
She's going to be best friend for the last eight years.
She knows everything about me.
Okay.
I want to hate her and make her sleep at her parents' house until we divorced,
but all I want to do is be near her again.
Yeah,
dude,
that's because,
okay.
Yeah,
dude,
she,
she was in a hurry up offense.
That's what happened here.
So now your scamper and trying to figure out what the fuck is going on.
And she,
you know,
she has an x three plays that she just called in the huddle.
That's why this,
this is why it sucks to be you right now.
Um,
one of my close friends tells me what I know is the right thing.
He goes,
let it go.
Don't bother with counseling.
What else has she done that you don't know about how he never trust her again?
Bill,
is it possible for me to forgive my wife?
Am I wasting my time?
Okay.
Um,
also I find out who this guy is and I really wish I hadn't.
Yeah,
dude,
of course.
All I wanted to do was show up at the job,
beat the shit out of him.
Like Ed Norton,
Pete's the blonde,
pretty boy up and fight club.
He writes,
I wanted to destroy something beautiful.
My other thought is since this guy also cheated on his girlfriend,
who we still with,
um,
he did it with my wife.
I threatened to tell his girlfriend what he'd done but not actually do it.
Yeah.
You don't want to do that that way.
He live in fear of coming home and her knowing everything because I told her or
he would try to beat me to it,
admit to it,
hopefully ending his relationship and getting terminal cancer and aids,
terminal cancer and aids.
And you know what?
You still being a gentlemen,
I still think that you're,
you're handling this with class wishing terminal cancer and AIDS on this guy.
Um,
I know you don't give a shit.
Of course I give a shit but not occupy.
Uh,
but I've got to occupy my mind.
So I thought I,
I,
I do it here.
Yeah.
Do,
why would you think I don't give a shit?
You know,
I mean,
I'm not a friend of yours,
but you know what I mean.
Give me a fucking break.
This is horrific.
Um,
all right,
your first question,
Bill,
is it possible for me to forget my wife?
Uh,
eventually you're going to have to,
uh,
and or you're going to go on a fucking tear
and you're going to meet some really damaged fucking women and they're going to
reinforce everything that you've now found out about your wife.
So you can't do that.
You're going to go on a fucking,
uh,
hate fuck pussy spree.
That is,
yeah.
You don't want to do that.
Um,
he said,
am I wasting my time?
Yeah,
dude,
it's over.
She's not happy.
She's not good at communicating.
Um,
she puts a lid on it,
you know,
until it boils over.
This is the deal,
dude.
You know what I,
this is going to kill you.
All right,
well let's go with the positive.
You don't have any kids with her.
Okay.
You can just walk away.
We had a prop and there was a,
there's nothing we can do,
so he didn't make it.
You just fucking walk away.
Just walk away.
It's over.
All right.
Um,
that's a good thing.
All right.
One thing,
you've had a bunch of kids with his fucking,
this person who for whatever reason,
couldn't say that they will.
I don't think that she wants you to wanting to fucking marry you.
I think she ignores her feelings.
She's actually having a fucking breakthrough right now while stomping all over
your fucking heart.
All right,
well,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I don't fuck her.
Give you a break,
dude.
You fucking,
you loved her with all your heart.
You say a mother's a sweetheart.
You got dogs.
You liked communicating,
dude.
You know something.
You're like the fucking guy.
You're the guy.
My girl wants me to be.
Every fucking woman wants a guy like that.
You know guy who actually wants to be married,
guy who actually comes home and communicates,
you know a guy who gets along with the mom and all that type of shit.
You're a family man.
All right?
Unfortunately,
you know you met the wrong person,
so forget that dude.
All right.
Forget it.
Fuck that.
It's over.
Walk away.
Walk away,
Dude.
Gimme a fucking bay.
You know what you talking about there?
You're talking about like the amount of fucking shit she has to go through
before she even learned how to just communicate or fucking emotions and the
frustration of that's going to meet every once in a while she's going to blow
somebody at work.
Are you wasting your time apps?
A fuckin lutely.
Okay.
Apps a Fuckin lutely.
And as far as like going there and trying to fuck over that other guy,
that other guy is,
he's already,
you don't need to fuck him over.
He's fucking himself over.
He's living it.
He's living a life of misery.
That life is miserable to fuck around with the person that you with with
somebody else.
That is a miserable life.
You know?
I Dunno.
I think it's something that a lot of guys do,
myself included back in the day and my twenties going into thirties trying to
fucking,
you know,
figure myself out.
I live in that life,
that whole fucking double.
It's horrible.
It's a fucking horrible thing.
Then in the end I ended up alone and I heard a lot of people and I was a
complete piece of shit.
So,
and believe me,
dude,
it was a miserable and ended up meet with me on a fucking futon.
So,
um,
yeah,
dude,
you're,
you know,
don't become a piece of shit now.
Don't judge other women like that.
Just fuck it.
You know?
Yeah.
Get out of it,
get out of it and just know that it's going to be a fucking a,
I dunno,
it's going to be a hundred yards of pain that you never fucking dealt with in
your life and you just got to go through it.
And,
um,
I,
I would say the next time you get with somebody,
uh,
make,
you know you're going to get serious with somebody who would make goddamn sure
that they know how to fucking communicate,
because that's,
that's a scary thing to get with a woman who doesn't know how to communicate
because that's something that they're supposed to teach us how to do.
You know,
in a way they make you better because you like,
oh,
I can just say,
uh,
no,
I don't feel like doing that without fucking punching the wall.
You know,
they do that set of cell you down.
If you get with some psycho and she can't settle you down.
I mean,
she's a,
she's damaged Christie,
no matter
what,
a 27 year old Virgin Jesus Christ.
Hey Billy,
I'd love to hear your humorous take on my pathetic situation.
First of all,
dude,
let's work on yourself estate.
All right?
You're already shitting all over yourself.
All right.
Hey,
watch this guy.
Watch him shit all over himself.
I'm a 27 year old virgin.
Oh Geez.
Uh,
that's what he wrote.
Now your first question is going to be,
how the fuck did that happen?
Well,
to protect myself,
I'd actually preserve,
prefer to keep my background is quite as possible.
Hey,
I'm not trying to get you to write yourself out.
Here's what I can say.
I come from a rich town inhabited by obnoxious con.
I was always the weird kid and very socially awkward people hated me no matter
how nice I was,
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
are you like a superhero that's like the exact same background of like every
fucking superhero movie,
isn't it?
It's probably cause nerds,
right?
Those movies because they don't have to fight.
And all of a sudden you're like,
what am I knew how to fly?
What if I could fly?
There was a guy who could save me.
Um,
and then they draw it and then nerds line up around the block to go see it.
Did you see the new Spiderman?
Yes.
It's exactly the other ones.
Um,
I was always the weird kid and very socially awkward people hated me no matter
how nice I was.
And eventually I came to hate myself and still do.
I called it dude,
I fucking called it.
Uh,
he's shitting all over himself.
Eventually it was discovered that I most likely have a mild case of Asperger's
syndrome,
which is a mild form of autism,
which is way out of my league.
Are you guys trying to make me look dumb?
I thought I did that.
I achieved that by how awful.
I read out loud.
Here we go.
That causes social ineptitude and Quirky personality traits.
Well,
I would go find a hawker with Asberger's.
That's the first thing I would do.
And you get the Fucking v off my back.
Definitely wear a condom.
See that's where my advice is going to be coming from.
You guys got some weird conversation in some ironic vehicle.
Um,
at least discovering this made me more of self aware and I've been able to clean
up my act over the last few years,
but I still have a lot of social anxiety,
shyness and very few friends.
On the flip side,
I'm actually pretty decent looking,
have a decent job in a laboratory.
These are fucking,
he's got to get bit by something radioactive and he's going to become a
superhero.
Uh,
and I'm a certified commercial pilot and do volunteer work.
Okay,
dude,
like you know something,
if,
if I was in the FBI,
like so many fucking red flags just went up there.
Uh,
okay.
That's the set up now.
Now for the question
first,
what the fuck would you do if you were in my situation?
I told you I'd get a hooker with Asperger's syndrome and you guys could just
bond
over that.
Uh,
I don't know.
Let me,
let me,
let me read all your questions.
I'm obviously kidding about trying to find a hook with Asperger's syndrome.
All right.
You couldn't find one that would be like needle in the haystack,
which you'd have to do is go to an escort service and requests that personally.
Um,
I would think
I'm looking for 36,
24 36 with Asperger.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hair color does not matter.
Yes,
I can hold,
um,
next.
If,
if eventually everything I ever do make it anywhere with a chick.
Should I tell her upfront about my status?
I had this conversation a few weeks ago with a friend who has a lot of romantic
experience and she said it would be extremely obvious that I'm new to the game
and that withholding that information could itself be detrimental.
But I also know that if I do tell a chicken 27 year old virgin,
she will demand an explanation before going any further and it will send up red
flags for the most.
What do you do?
Belt.
Thanks for doing your awesome podcast and go fuck yourself.
All right.
This is what I would do.
Okay.
I would just start hitting on every check that fucking interest me and I would
be just totally honest.
Okay.
Tell him,
tell her what your,
your,
uh,
your situation is and you know,
if she doesn't accept it,
then fucker let her walk and then you don't have to deal with any of the
bullshit.
You didn't know.
You just,
you just fast forwarded through a three year fucking horrific relationship.
Um,
I would just be up front with people.
I wouldn't open it with Ai.
You have beautiful eyes and I have Asperger's.
I wouldn't do that,
you know?
Um,
I would work on my self esteem.
I wouldn't talk shit.
You just,
you shit on yourself right out of the gate.
I mean,
obviously I knew you were going to do that when you said you were 27 year old
virgin and,
and you probably going to go that route,
but uh,
think good thoughts about yourself,
man.
I know that's kind of like simple,
but you know,
you gotta like you got to amp yourself up a little bit,
go out there and you know,
you don't have to go find the check.
He had drains but just go out.
You don't get to tell some girl you got fucking Asberger's syndrome.
You don't,
why don't you just do that with somebody that you're really interested in,
but it's just want to go out and get laid.
Just go out there and start hitting on checks,
turning into a game so you don't have to deal with the pain of the rejection.
Just be like,
all right,
I don't have the balls to to take the next step.
Whatever that step is.
Peeling yourself off the fucking wall.
Striking up a conversation,
just saying hello to a pretty girl.
She walks down the street.
Just try to get over that fucking hurdle and give you permit yourself permission
to suck and you just,
you gradually build it up.
It's like learn how to play guitar.
You're not going to pick it up and immediately be able to play all your songs.
You learned a couple of fucking cords,
you know?
Then your fingers hurt,
right and you get frustrated,
but you keep coming back and eventually you can fucking play.
Pussy is no different.
That's what I would do.
Put The ass burger on the back burner.
Who knows?
Do it.
Maybe not as fucked up as you think you are socially.
You know what I mean?
Maybe you've got a sense of humor under there.
I think you do your shit on yourself in a funny way.
You don't spin it around that way.
Do you have any interests?
Go,
go to,
oh,
go to a fucking,
I dunno.
Whatever.
You know,
you fly kites,
go to some flying a kite,
convince you there's gotta be some woman there also likes Kate's.
I know that was an overly simplified things,
but I,
that's what I would do.
All right.
And then when you go to like a hookup with somebody,
uh,
they,
you know Ajay yet,
tell him if you don't,
don't know what you're doing to watch a couple of fucking pornos,
you know,
you'll get the idea.
Actually,
no,
don't do that.
Don't do that because then you'll suck and start slapping them around.
Yeah,
don't do that.
I know what to tell you,
dude.
I write and get,
buy some books.
I say go buy some,
buy some books in that,
that,
uh,
that part of the bookstore that,
you know,
if bookstores exist anymore going,
gone line has got to be plenty of information.
I bet if you literally looked up finger banging technique as you looked at how
to kiss,
I bet this is going to be reams of fucking information.
I've never done that cause I never had to.
Oh,
just kidding.
Of course I had,
do you think that I didn't wish that fucking information was around way back in
the day when he had no id,
just practice a kissing your fucking pillow and tried to overhear conversations
in the fucking high school cafeteria and tried to figure out what people were
talking about.
That's all I had to do.
You had,
you had the whole world at your fingertips,
you know,
so when you'd done in the laboratory working with radioactive shit before you
get bit by something,
you know,
once you go on and get late.
Yeah.
Before you learn how to fly.
All right.
[inaudible] wow.